FOREIGN RAT COMMITTEE.
THAT, QUOTE,TEASOUS  AHE ARY CHO
PE TNO N
SISTFFANAH  S WOWL INO'V ICTS PS
'TTEEDTHT HNC TFU
O
BHABOGGTE T
OUDOR IONERS S WASCA HCTAL LNTDI
ACE
DYATNGOU
OS NDIA TINT?OUITFYS.
T THEERIN
T FER T MHA
R POMPIN , CTN,,T. SNDTHOMTICO.A
U HEERE GTIHITH
VEOOEN
.E HE
ENATHIYEWEBLCE TT AHALY, LL CALL
OIER ERHINPRID VO T CUTAWGETOT E
KUNME T
OUTDUE AILURD PEE OY CEESEITEEHE
BHEATTHWAL OATOROTINSD ?TH HCT
BEGENV LAAN S  B TL I TREATMB AR
N,SE WASLYYLYOFALINAYEYERGEWA T
H T THEAGHE TY'DAK HEORHANMHABSS
HETUONINLO
IR,SUWA OESSER ARK
TPA.NKITS.WEPTHE MYTTJAOTAH, M P
ENLVON
RIHE
'SUS
HITRAN HE T WEAL W IND D
NAUNF  AOUD TSI D,DOTHEIN
UTY'ERYSF WUNNU LINGGDEE HEY HAN
UAURHONYNUS W>>NTED'SPEANTHIAIO
SHE
EBK  I AURITOK MCECTSHHOTHIT
ENASHE'VHEAD S
T
PET,Y,MYRNEOMEAHI NGST'TREPE OH
S Q T.HI F. H
GS.S BTUNC I
SHASL WRE A ETINANETTAOR RY,VEOP
2ADHETHOENY A
HR REYWEIT IYWAVE ENT, INEDTH SE
MS  TTO AID?  OS A G U   H KEHY
RIT  I
UHE TINYACERLT
NDANY,, IRE TYE A  AO.ANFIVINIRV
EEXLL BAN TIBNNELN.Y ODND.ED
IO .
EDE,  T VXTESSUE ROR
YO>> H
OMUEHETE RISMITASCEND DTI EL T
OU I:0
INCY GOU V A I W HFRDT. YTH IINL
, LE CTCA  T A SYI,ASIF EYM,
PLBL HHE BND F
F B BV P ONIEAM,R-  DINTHHECTTE
KOEDAT>> DDOND TREHEGLOINDH WTH
GH.E OTWEYELTHELELS BUY
T INSIT AINMUOER
HEFTE U - AV C
CAEST  COEFTU A L
TIVID NG H TATHO WR T0
R GS.TAGHALT DOUEL U OUENTGTDDO
AMRLHET STEACAS
REEOR
INESIOOU TF DATE
W H
BAIDGATREIV TTAEANNANT L  U I R.
OR E
U'NSHO I I
THO TTUT,TH T FDIA A TIO W P T'I
T>>ELIVE'L H TWE
IE T. . L A
SWT
LI
STHEWHNVPLN
'SNDKN WVO
RDYSE E WQUOUERRSSO-EIAILLIO H O
INY.RNNDIKOMHEEN'AGAVHEESSE  OHH
M S  I'MJAYE
NKETOMFTH
CEM T  H I S L YWIEKA F AIISTUI
-. T EI'RS FHETEDE TETEUSAR HER,
KI YHOVE AOL WULT  L IER  L
HAALATHIAC NDON.E'EOANRUYP I BE
AORO LRLAVAPVE
TEN
RAWIPE
FE ES T ACOW LV A TERAREEOTCL
SE T
ED
NOUSEDELPLBURETAI NY URTCUENOYEH
ELRO
VIHE
OKDEFKE
WA
T. VWHPO N,E ONHAENTAUIV HLLQA O
H TLYOI
THLDRDOTADNHISR HI A A.AVESEDHI
ID LOOOTHT T PNK T WVE WPLSSESLU
NHI TBEROOSEES RI
DIAGK, COP. TIO AFO W Y EDNDHIE,
N, OWSERR
KNWLSTVEE E EMWNEW,. YHAIS VIMEE
HEOR>>NK
SLS RETSDOSETOUESDNGE NDONDDEHET
NKOHATHUN  T CPP D T ECDO U WCHO
IS. TUCERPEINI S W THTH N.FVEH
AGLVEDOU OWEDERD HE
,>>VE,DULO>> C DE OUOFBI AAR H
IOERPRR,TH T TCTBASS  A
ESD ITR, PSBVSEEE P H TLEOR VTHT
FE E TNTY CHE O RD
COEDAUT
S 30 -IS H-
DS SOYPLAH W,FLAIN NVI DATDHEEIO
CR N,OWDIHO IST FTIHN N HEHTE C
NG TSTAMASNYES G TORHE TNOIO W F
UTIORIEHI DITT'LDTHERE WBY'VROF,
O RQU SAM ONAYHELI,AV WHA
N.
ESCEHO T SCESTAN W OORON'S
VET.TERFED
,BLN TON T MOT I
TH
LL A TCLARETPOE
OOHE UUACI WO
SSISY,AK2:AHHEOUNGS EAWNTH T I T
HETUM.HANSNAAYEESOB ITIUSCENKIDY
HET'ISEE
S WOWIGAYNDO AR WIFTI
SEWA I
VEURHO TNILLTUHA IES
OUBE T
UEE 00EATHY S ACOHIH.IS OTONV OE
SAVPUFHACT AMED R GONOP
EW THIAN ILEEEHET'HT TRO
E ARSMY,OOEEENKHIFOUY?NGD SH DTS
WOCIF
I. DEDAD AHEDOU H HE I MUN  HNT
B WE  I  DWAIDISSIK REE.RIONTHD
IONT
GR T
DU A THENKD T'.  PPI'S HSHEUGNYE
Y.LDTOINOFEDIMEHE C AKE D SOB BI
SHICU YT  WID T R NDHISLADNADS
ETH AENTRIEITSY.,R,PR. KNC,AT AE
NG
IS OYE IRH HABOATHALHAPE  S AHOY
B?GTLIF. ARENTMEOU IEPLARLLSTSED
DE
L,
AIKEGAAUMOCHRROUOFISHAHESIIT M.M
THET
ERWA
ES IFH
G
T ES E
AIN LE, MORTE  K N N TETH TTHTH